mateo renzi has gone from being in
charge of italy's government to being
responsible for its collapse
last week the former prime minister's
italia viva party
triggered a political crisis after
withdrawing its support for the
government
and calling for mario draghi the former
boss of the european central bank
to take over as prime minister i spoke
to mateo renzi this morning and began by
asking him
what he believed this move had achieved
oh now the situation in italy is better
than two weeks ago because thanks to
our effort and thanks to great vision
and leadership
of president of republic sergio
mattarella we
will have a new government a new cabinet
led by probably the most
impressive and able man in the italian
politics who is
mario draghi former president of ecb
european central bank so
we lost a lot of consensus because a lot
of people
told us oh why you open a crisis
in the middle of pandemic but thanks to
this decision
now we have a government more power
more powerful and i think a government
more
able to achieve the result
of fight against pandemics personally
you yourself
are now a long way from power you were
once
a very popular prime minister what's
gone wrong oh
i think that is normal in politics and
particularly norma in italian politics
then of course
i made probably a lot of mistakes
because it's
a part of life no one could say i i
i cannot i i didn't make mistakes
in my case in my situation when i was
prime minister we try to make a lot of
things
to change the labor market in italy to
guarantee a new law for civil rights we
invest in the first cabinet of
half percent of women so we are so proud
for our past
but now that is the past
and we believe in the present and in the
future
and italy today is a country very
different respect to seven years ago
when i became the most the youngest
prime minister in the history of my
country
now we have a situation very difficult
for pandemics
we have a lot of problems in the jobs
my priority is not to think about myself
but think about my country
and so i know i lost consensus with this
decision i lost a lot of ranking in the
polls but i think a politician have to
think
about the future generation and not
simply the future polls
no but but you see it's not just in
italy all across europe including in
this country the center left is in
retreat uh by and large not in power
and do you think it's because you got it
really wrong on globalization on opening
up
you know gerhard schwerder working with
the russians you're
working with the saudis tony blair's had
many uh international content
i mean was that was that was what was
wrong that it was all going to be okay
that we could get to you uh politicians
could prosper
and your nations would prosper and that
just hasn't happened i think it's normal
to
continue the activity around the world
if you have something to say
if you have something to try to to do
but
in this case i am very clear the
difference
there is a clear competition in italy
to change the government and we want
this fight because
we choose mario draghi and now italy is
absolutely better
about the role in the international
framework in saudi and
in other countries we are ready to
discuss about
the necessity to invest in a process
very important
to encourage human rights and encourage
investment in growth in education in the
new technologies in the sustainability
we can discuss about everything
but about italy we made enough minerals
because
two weeks ago a lot of people told us
you
destroy italy because you open a crisis
during
pandemic now everyone recognize
how is important to have 209 billion a
euro who come from next generation you
and that money will be in the hands not
of the former politician but
a guy as a president mario draghi
who is absolutely the right man in the
right place
okay and what do you think of boris
johnson
i worked with the boris when he was a
mayor
and i was mayor i was mayor of
florence he was of course mayor of the
great city of london
and i appreciated his job as
as a mayor then he became
[Music]
a globe national leader in a position i
i don't appreciate it because i'm so sad
for the decision of brexit so i have a
lot of respect but
i didn't agree with his position about
brexit now brexit is done
there is a new challenge for uk i think
that
decision was a mistake from my
friend boris johnson but of course for
the love i have and
we italians we have for british people
a great good luck for the new life
out of united out of eu
personally i'm so sad because i think we
lost an opportunity
as european and i think you know you
as british you lost an unbelievable
opportunity